Wassup ballas? Got somethin’
special fo yo asses today. Not only am I about
to drop some mad knowledge on da illest chapter
in The Brothers Karamazov,
but I’m a show you how you can check some
similar philosophizin’ in The Dark Knight.
So here’s my special on The Grand Inquisitor.
It’s a ridiculous thing, but I want
to tell it to you.
Now The Grand Inquisitor is a poem
dat Ivan lays on his bro Alyosha while they conversatin bout God and mankind.
Lemme break it down for ya.
Back during the Spanish Inquisition,
homies gettin BLAZED left and
right for not keepin it Catholic... but not in a good way.
In short, sh** is fu**ed up.
Then outta nowhere JESUS HIMSELF swings into
town and starts healing the sick like a
boss.
When the top dawg in charge, the
Grand Inquisitor, sees this holy-sh** goin down,
he says “AW HELL NAW JESUS” and
throws his ass behind bars. Then he say “Look, JC,
why’d you gotta go and give mankind
the freedom to choose between good and evil?
What, you think humans be noble enough to make
this choice themselves? NAW BLOOD.
With that freedom, they ALWAYS gonna choose evil. Man
needs someone to MAKE him do good.
The worst thing you ever did was not force them to bow down to you. And that’s what I do.
I save them from themselves by jackin' their freedom
and makin' em bow down to me.
This poem bringin' up all sorts of
questions for us to marinate on.
Like how human beings gonna act when they
ain’t got no laws holdin' them down?
Not only is the Inquisitor spittin'
this to ol' JC, but this is exactly tha kind
of truth dat the Joker layin on
Batman in The Dark Knight.
See, their morals, their code... it’s a bad joke, dropped at the first sign of trouble.
They’re only as good as the
world allows them to be.
I'll show you –when the chips are down, these civilized people... they’ll eat each other.”
And the Joker ain’t all talk. Erry
one of his terrorist acts goes to prove
the Inquisitor’s raw truth: at it’s core,
man is a viscious fu**in animal,
and, when the sh** goes down, that beastly side comes
out.
"If Coleman Reese isn't dead in 60 minutes, then I blow up a hospital.”
"Commissioner, do you really think an ordinary citizen would try to kill this man?"
"Commissioner!"
But luckily there’s hope for the homies
of G-Town. In the face of all this chaotic mess,
there’s one brutha who thuggin righteous enough to inspire people to do good:
Harvey Dent, Gotham’s White
Knight.
Just like the Inquisitor sayin:
human beings ain’t legit enough to follow
Christ just cuz. Naw. They need dat bread
first. Matter of fact, they’ll even throw
their savior to the curb to get what they
fiendin for.
Well the truth hits hard in The Dark Knight. Cuz dem crooked-ass cops in Gordon’s
posse gonna give up their Ideal just so they
can stack dat cheddar.
"What exactly did you think they were gonna do?"
"They got me early on, my mother's hospital bills and.."
"Don't!"
Now ain’t errybody think people dat
bent in da head. At first, Batman reppin da
big JC by thinkin that if given the opportunity,
mankind gonna choose good.
But after seein what The Joker’s
whack-ass philosophy did to Harey Dent,
ol' Bats ain’t the same no mo. Batman realize
that stoppin the Joker ain’t enough.
He gonna have to step off his Christly grind and get all Inquisitor-style in order to save Gotham's Soul.
Like the Inquistor preachin, the
only way to make life bearable for da masses
is to “enslave them by a miracle” and
“give them someone to bow down to.”
So BAM, Batman gotta make up some
bullsh** in order to keep the masses dumb
and happy. So he lies, jivin that Harvey Dent
kept it real til the end and didn’t smoke
no innocent hustlas. Even though Harvey Dent aint nothin but a fake-ass savior, it don’t matter.
What do matter is that mankind got
an ideal to bow down to to save them from themselves.
And the sacrifice for lying to make
make all dem fools happy?
Somebody's gotta suffer.
On the real, the truth can be so
damn fugly that it’s gotta be kept on the DL
for the good of the hood.
"'Cause sometimes...truth isn't good enough."
"Sometimes people deserve more..."
Yo, I hope you enjoyed this episode.
It may not have been the one you needed,
but it’s the one you deserve. And hey, if you
diggin my cinema criticism, let me know.
Take it easy, y’all. Peace!